the American Academy of Pediatrics
published a new study this morning
calling for a mandatory safety standard
to eliminate window blinds with cords
the study found blinds with courts
continue to pose a serious strangulation
risk killing on average about one child
a month researchers note it is
impossible to supervise children
constantly these events can happen
quickly and awareness shows us what
happened to one family and what why not
everybody agrees that a mandatory
government fix is needed here and a good
morning good morning Gail the Consumer
Product Safety Commission and blind
manufacturers say the government does
not need to force manufacturers into
switching the cordless blinds that a new
standard developed through a voluntary
process over several years is just
around the corner but parents like the
couple you're about to meet say if that
process works so well they would not be
marking the one-year anniversary of
their young daughter's death like her
namesake four-year-old presley marie
Eastburn loved to sing her parents
Jeromy and Carol say they miss hearing
her voice and seeing her joy everywhere
she went she always saw the good in
things I miss her holding my face and
looking into my eyes telling me you know
how much she liked me a year ago Presley
was in the family room watching TV alone
for about 10 minutes when her parents
say she made her way to the window and
became entangled in the cord attached to
the blinds carol was on the phone with
her husband I heard was horrible
blood-curdling scream you screamed what
was it that you saw it was my daughter's
body it was like all the life had been
sucked out of her she dialed 9-1-1 I
just told Presley mommy's here hold on
for mommy I love you I love you I love
you but it was too late
Presley had been strangled she died five
days later now doctors in the journal
Pediatrics are calling for immediate
action saying in a report that window
blinds were involved in more than 16
and injuries and 271 deaths among
children over a 25-year period dr. Gary
Smith co-authored the study it's just
completely unacceptable that we continue
to see children die from this cause when
we've known about this problem for over
70 years
he says children often can't call out
for help the child can pull this queer
right here this video from an advocacy
group shows how easily they can become
entangled manufacturers say they're
addressing the problem in a statement
their trade group says a voluntary
process with the Consumer Product Safety
Commission will result next year in the
most significant change to the window
covering safety standard ever with a
requirement that all blinds sold in
retail stores or online be cordless or
have inaccessible cords a change they
say should cover more than 80% of
products sold I consider this a success
story where we're at CPSC acting
chairman Ann Marie Buerkle says
mandatory standards take a long time to
develop the voluntary standard process
is far more nimble and quicker and I'm
very encouraged that we're about to
cross the finish line and make sure that
we have safe products out in the
marketplace yet earlier this year the
CPSC s former chairman called the
standards process flawed and safety
advocates say they're concerned because
the standard still does not cover many
custom products ordered by consumers the
industry insists its efforts will reduce
the risks to children how do you respond
to that based on what you know are there
dead children because I would say they
haven't done enough last year alone
children who died included a two year
old from Florida a three year old from
Ohio a three year old from Texas and
Presley every day
the little girl who used to sing along
with mom - a favorite story
I would always sing to her as long as
I'm living my baby you'll be and she
would turn right back around to me
and she would sing it as long as I'm
living my mommy he'll be well the
eastburns say they were told the blinds
they were sold had child safety features
they claimed did not work properly they
are suing both the manufacturer and the
retailer of their blinds the retailer's
attorney told us they did not install
the blinds and the manufacturer did not
respond to our request for comment but
it's a warning to parents and who have
lines you need cordless blinds if at all
possible or keep those cords way out of
reach and it seems like such a
no-brainer if you can change it and make
it safer I like the father saying are
there dead children to me what what more
do you need to know
well the discussions are going on for a
long time and the manufacturers say look
we're making big changes here but you
can understand from a parent's point of
view that's not fast enough and there
were kids lost no thank you in a
important warning thinking